les gens comprennent pas que on est sur
terre parce que les a pas d'armes pas du
monde ces cinq comme ça
[Musique]
et
c'est patrice l'outil eux je suis et la
gare dans la vie moi je fais ce métier
là parce que j'aime les armes
nous quand on a acheter c'est un
botaniste avait de la maison aussi
c'était sûrement préféré qu'elle
l'aimait beaucoup puis ces enfants ont
vécu ce bordeaux-là besoin de vendre la
maison pour parce qu'on est un petit
famille tous
[Musique]
mais ça va faire des grosses fleurs un
petit peu comme des tulipes ouverte
blanc
ça commence rose il vient de plus en
plus blanc le fonds reste quand même
mais c'est pas long ça fait riche de
sens mal
[Musique]
mais c'est un homme qu'on doit laisser
de lui même il faut faire ce qu'il veut
parce qu'un amas forêt pas besoin de
tels alliés savent tous que sa demande
ce qu'on laisse très inquiet
[Musique]
c'est plate pour mon métier
mais un homme logiquement sacha blais
pas
construit trop vite parce qu'on essaie
d'aller trop vite pour la justesse d'un
arbre c'est vraiment la saison et des
arbres qui poussent plus vite que
d'autres mais on était vraiment
l'ensemble c'est les plus forts c'est le
pire ses dessins sont solides les gros
chêne sessile on a poussé
[Musique]
je n'ai lag pas vraiment car le joie je
veux juste enlever le moment puis
ce qui touche aux sources est tous là
parce que
[Musique]
c'est la vie les ans ont fait de longues
ça fait ça sent bon c'est beau ça change
tout le temps une vase est beau en été
c'est beau
mes enfants aiment son grain de leur
jeu ça me prend des âmes
[Rires]
[Musique]